previously on the walking dead well this
is as far as we're going
oh it's him but no and then up there in
the corner room I heard crying coming uh
we can't just leave her damn right we
can
cam 90 this is the player yeah dad I
don't know how hard it's gonna be to get
her out of that room oh ah ah how the
gum bread
my name is peridot in this episode I had
a sit awkwardly close to the camera
all right what's up man I didn't speak
is that prime Walker killer this should
be able to take those prime walk akela
Oh BRB can't target forgot all right hi
there we go
come here Sal is sexy all right yes as
for Yamaha I like to admit that all your
face oh don't think you gotta do
something again oh [ __ ] oh no Asian
don't die okay good get him Lee oh wait
um Lee oh [ __ ] I'm sorry about your eye
bruh
nice not for sure for shit's all cars oh
no he's gonna be home how convenient
look at that hello you mad brah Oh what
is this
I don't touch me bro oh you're deaf I
can touch me hey you want this to snack
right Jenny on the phone if your nipple
was in your face it's pointing it out
there dude where'd you weapon go into
that I speak size tool holy [ __ ] that's
just how I roll
now we've got this are you two done pip
I leveled up to level two and gained
fire axe - [ __ ] yeah that should help
oh you better believe it can I jump can
I super jump am i charging a jump here
oh I love cam sneaking all right yeah
all right cool why don't you guys like
ah just in case this goes to hell good
plank right we'll be right behind you
huh I don't know what I feel about that
I would be so scared if I did those in
real life I would not do this in real
life
I got sightings no of course I don't say
men I'm a badass all right let's see
what were you going on all right
Shh guys guys hey hey how you done
are you don't you like to dance I like a
dancer I'll show you next one that's not
really dance mode I didn't make that
uh-huh
now your anger aren't yet how about this
girl don't be scared it's only a black
man with an axe I'm just kidding that's
racist and it's racist
what hello in there I'm sorry we're here
to help
funny bigoted eyes you know anything
uh-huh if you open up when I mean is
somewhere safer we've got a group in
town
he is pretty cold she's in trouble hey
nation TV sometimes we're coming in and
yeah yeah that should do it
you might want to break through that
board first thank you I'm fine how about
I break for you
all right there we go how the hell did
he set that up anyway like how do you do
it outside the door it doesn't make
sense coming out all right fine
Jesus Christ
ah she's a bee Oh God
I said stay away we need to get you help
it's too late
it's sure she's been bitten what I told
you I said go away I'm bitching but you
wouldn't just leave
what's calm down can you just explain I
won't be fine my boyfriend was bitten
you get sick and you die and then you
come back and you kill anything you can
find is that way friend Len I don't want
that he's jealous not Christian please
just leave me please go I like her faith
is a shame she's difficult Erica that
won't live um okay leave okay
we'll leave just try to take care of
yourself whatever time you have left
Oh what's she doing gun so can I borrow
it back off you mean borrow give it to
me I can just you know end this and then
then there's no problem
whoa whoa I don't want to be one of them
they're their satanic yeah pretty cool
ah dick triple dot please this is crazy
please but here's my number it's just
two seconds step back and I can be with
my face so creepy oh ha ha what are you
doing
no that question mm-hmm well what's
gonna happen oh that's gonna happen oh
my god
Carly's fine good no I'm not the Chinese
whoa take it easy
oh [ __ ] I want to help you can't do it
[ __ ] just relax now
damn you need to think this through
anything me might say fine to a doctor
it would be okay that's all just no no
sorry it was obvious she was gonna do it
she's difficult carry that it's not
gonna live don't look at me like that
I'm heartless I thought she was pretty
cold I'm sad she died too but it's not
I'm not Jesus Christ
I would probably throw up too so it's
okay I'm just curious about what you're
eating that looks like you're eating
urine right there
bye good evening during sure oh no
they're coming
get in had a car oh [ __ ]
oh do we just get Ryan over everyone all
right
yeah we're fine we had some close calls
but we missed your mustache now we'll
Kia we're okay mmm
I've got a few cans of gas for your
pickup in the trunk of my car good to
hear it and things back here why our
friend is still in an atom
you won't sir oh yeah I watch stress
whereas next order of business is given
those pills out of the pharmacy all
right
why did they the why did I don't want to
keep calling invasion I want to know his
name
alright I guess we'll just head out what
is his name
Glen doesn't seem variation anyway my
guys have stirred I'm sorry
and all right let's talk Carly hey Carly
what's that so why do you what are you
listening around with there a radio I
can't get it to work though yeah let me
have a look cuz I know how to do these
things oh cool I can do it alright let
me just adjust the volume that's a
classic mistake right there uh-huh
still nothing all right let me try
putting it on cuz you never know
I'm safer again god damn it that's as
far as my skills goes look behind it
are there any batteries no I
voilá risa loosely there we go do you
know Beverly I'm a series of epic yeah
of course I mean yeah of course you knew
that ha ha ha leads to Thanks I wouldn't
even really know what to look for okay
good talk good tie why is he giving her
that look I'm a rapier now I kill you
laughter what look
okay how does it do it Socrates he do it
again please Oh
step outside have a look around ah dude
let's sue subtle yet no the gate out
there is closed
make sure to the phone oh about that not
right now alright let me know if you
want to oh wow I'll forever remember
that moment Easter egg hunt
cool car right [ __ ]
I'm gonna do it again
uh-huh what's up haven't I
I missed you what's up everything okay
everything okay there yeah I'm glad I'm
glad Clementine you're my darling you
know that you're my little sugar bunny
set out my Allard have been in here I
should I should not I should touch ah
Peter Parker yeah we're going out I
shouldn't waste time here but who do I
ahead I love the music it's a shame it
changed because Matt music it's pretty
cool let's talk to these girls we need
to get back to Fort Lauderdale
we'll do our damndest Haley honey gave
that old man hell yeah yeah we got
pushed you know you don't have to tell
me I was ready to tear the man's head
off anyway we can't and I appreciate
your support
Thank You Lee you got my I got your back
even though I don't really like your son
but what can you do about it
so how's duck doing he's okay
I guess it's just a shock we're lucky as
hell nobody got nabbed on the way in
here look cute how is she doing
yeah how is she doing
she's gonna good she's a tough one right
there she's just a little girl Ken were
you saying Lee
she spent days surviving on her own yeah
absolutely
not just any little girl can do that
she's special
hey you guys alright we're just fine
considering how about you duck your
mustache Nix we've all been through
Laureus they're white how I look sign
now
hang tight I suppose seems pretty
dangerous out there so we ought to wait
for things to clear up you said your
family was from here in Macon that's
right
where are they so we'll definitely and
they're gone
go on oh my goodness do you think how I
just know right
kanna's not don't question me Lee [ __ ]
you got a second yeah I'm troops that
what do you want back on Hershel's farm
uh-huh yeah
I panicked you know I'm not proud of it
I'm glad we got to talk about this you
know what I forgive her I guess
but I can't stop seeing him in my head
yeah that's rough I killed that boy you
they could have saved him together you
didn't have a choice
you think you do when you look back on
it but in a moment
when things are really out of control
you don't have any choice I guess
honestly he could have saved him he
could have just put down duck try to let
it go that's the best thing anyway but
hey you shouldn't push yourself for it
man it's tough times for everyone right
here
I mean your kid looks stupid that's got
to be pretty terrible to do but try to
get some rest I'm here to your show evil
I'm just kidding it's fine like an end
it's fine it's fine
what is this don't over remember the
very well it's been a while since I
rendezvous I guess there's this
so I don't know if anyone realized that
but the parents his parents were the
owner of this store so we're looking at
photographs of his parents
all right so I want to head out let's do
it
how are we doing good you want to go
have a look around outside let's do it
let's have a look around okay kinda
looks like a fatter version of me
pheasant a with shorter hair and awesome
t-shirts they're so sexy I can't get
over it
I just want to stroke my what are they
doing over there ah Swedish massage
you just eat far as I can tell me that
they look so skinny and whatever's left
comes back is one of them why don't they
eat themselves then it's rotten you
think it might be more than a couple
days before all this gets sorted out
alright so we need to work on a plan I
could use my fire axe on the line
what is this too bad we don't have a way
to come out here and watch the news
would be nice to know what's going on
elsewhere but Lana's in rough shape is
all I know
yeah did you guys try to get in there
and get weapons I did but it was too
risky
then a bunch of guys showed up and they
tried uh-huh and they died what happened
I think there most of who you see
wandering around up oh [ __ ] no kidding
huh
well what about his know it's him what
do you know that guy
ah no kinda me as a familiar face I'm
around here anybody you know ah sheet up
shut up dog
says he shot your mouth ah poorly in the
uniform though he could have worked at
the drugstore
and died with keys in his pocket uh-huh
that's her blonde take a lot of effort
to make it safe enough to go out there
and see if he has
if somehow prove that he worked here I
think it'd be worth it all right I'll
call what I can find
we need to prove it well the photos out
there that guy over there is the keys
how can you be sure we just talked about
it but I have this letter that boy in
the photo worked here the keys being on
him is as good a bed as we could make
yeah I agree
still figure out how to get out there
get them nah you wouldn't need long
right just a few circles well you can't
really check his pants track them and
buy you some time
how you gonna do that that's a hasty
fortification job over there oh yeah
didn't work all right so when you'd find
something to distract them with maybe
going back it's best thing to do yeah I
think going back get back inside okay
all right breasts
I'm going to end subset that I can pull
if you enjoy scrap hey and I'll see you
next era whatever army
I know you were you ready
[ __ ] water I'm never going to what is
this never go near water again
hey boy nice baby your knee could be
able to stair-step hi babe
that's okay hello oh thank god a vagina